this little girl is Kwon ji-yong she's
woken up in a hospital bed after living
through the most terrifying ordeal of
her very young life
[Applause]
this is her 24 hours ago the
six-year-old was rescued from a sinking
ferry there were hundreds of passengers
on board including Kwan's mother and
father they haven't been heard from
since like so many others who were still
missing above the water this is all that
can be seen of the seawall she was on a
routine overnight crossing ferrying her
passengers between the mainland and Jeju
Island but just hours from shore with
land in sight disaster struck
[Music]
the ferry sank with more than 450 people
on board now some of her dead have been
returned to shore on board
many schoolchildren classmates on a
field trip together the search for them
and other passengers has continued
through the night and into a second day
with so many still missing there's hope
desperation that survivors will somehow
be found some families have even hired
their own boat to take them out to the
site of the disaster but with each
passing hour without news that hope
turns to fuel this man is the ferries
captain he doesn't want his face to be
seen but he did have these words for the
grief-stricken relatives I am really
sorry I'm deeply ashamed I don't know
what to say the apology will do nothing
to ease the distress of the families
they are without their loved ones and
they are without an explanation this
film taken by a passenger shows
terrified schoolchildren huddled on
board the sinking ship wearing
lifejackets but otherwise helpless just
waiting to be reached by rescuers many
lives were saved but many more are still
missing and the chances of finding any
more survivors including Kwon ji-yong as
parents are fading fast
Ashish Joshi sky news